.
Notre encoyé spécial,
Jean-François Bélanger.
- Extraction to Mariupol!
Extraction to Mariupol!
- Elles manifestent avec
toute la force du désespoir.
Toutes ont survécu à l'enfer
de Marioupol et sont bien
décidées à tout faire pour
que leurs pères, leurs frères,
leurs fils, leurs maris soldats
en sortent aussi.
(slogans)
"Ce sont tous des frères
d'armes là-bas. Ils font partie
de notre famille, dit-elle.
Nous devons nous battre
pour eux, pour essayer
de les sauver."
Cela fait maintenant plus
d'un mois que des centaines de
soldats ukrainiens sont coincés
dans les bunkers et tunnels sous
l'usine Azovstal de Marioupoe M.
Ils ont réussi à évacuer
les civils, mais eux
s'y trouvent toujours.
Bombardés sans relâche par
l'armée russe, ils multiplient
les appels à l'aide
pour tenter d'en sortir.
"Nous savons que nous avons peu
de chances de survivre si no
sommes capturés, dit-il, il est
donc impensable de se rendre
dans ces conditions."
(chant)
Chaque jour de survie est donc
une petite victoire en soi,
un pied de nez à l'ennemi
qu'ils célèbrent à leur façon.
Mais leations avec
l'extérieur sont difficiles.
Cela fait maintenant un mois
et demi qu'Olya n'a pas
de nouvelles de son mari, Dima.
ement mariés, ils avaient
plein de projets,
et toute la vie devant eux.
Mais la guerre est venue
tout chambouler. Depuis,
Olya se repasse en boucle dans
sa tête leur dernier échange.
"Je lui ai dit que je voulais
vraiment avoir des enfants
à son retour, dit-elle, beaux
comme lui et intelligents
comme moi. Il m'a dit
qu'il le voulait aussi."
Ils se sont qu'ils s'aimaient,
qu'ils se reverraient bientôt.
Puis, plus rien.
Alors, comme les autres femmes
des combattants d'Azovstal,
rate pas une occasion
de se faire entendre.
Comme ici, devant le palais
présidentiel.
L'action pour s'occuper
l'esprit, pour s'accrocher
à l'espoir. Pour s'empêcher
d'envisager le pire.
"Nous voulons que notre
président nous explique pourquoi
il ne sauve pas nos hommes,
dit-elle, pourquoi il ne demande
s pays
pour les sortir."
Un message visiblement entendu.
"Nous continuons d'aider
nos gens d'Azovstal, ditle prés,
Des négociations sont
actuellement en cours pour
tenter de les évacuer."
Des négociations sous
l'égide d'influents médiateurs
étrangers. Mais pour les
combattants d'Azovstal, il est
déjà minuit moins une. Beaucoup
d'entre eux sont lourdement
blessés et n'ont pas accès
à des soins de santé.
Tous le savent : leur temps est
compté. Sur ce mur se trouvent
les photos des soldats
ukrainiens victimes de la guerre
avec la Russie depuis 2014.
4500 hommes et femmes morts
pour la patrie.
Un lourd tribut. Et pourtant,
le bilan actuel essssssssss
élevé car le mur n'a pas été mis
à jour depuis deux ans.
Et de toute façon, il n'y
aurait plus assez de place
pour le
Ici Jean-François Bélanger,
Radio-Canada, Kie